man being number four though uh I do
agree with that I think it I think it
[__] season one season one was such a
such I came out of [__] nowhere and
just kind of like it was and it was one
of those shows where I could I could
easily again recommend it to anyone be
like just check it out it's fun I'm
going to be that guy you don't think
it's that good I'm going to be that guy
uh Mob psyo deserves the spot mob
deserves this spot what I think when
we're talking about popularity right we
have to think if you're a an anime fan
who's got five anime to watch and then
then clocking out of anime you're done
you've done your we're not we're not
we're not arguing if we understand the
popularity cuz I understand the
popularity does it deserve this much
popularity I yeah I mean mob definitely
deserves it but mob is also a show that
you watch after you've already watched
like 20 anime I will argue this point
one I will argue this point once I
figure out what placement mob is in this
list can we can we go
down M where is Mob is Mob even there is
Mob even there there it is there
okay that deserves to be way high 2
million fa it's below seven deadly
sins it's B AR make a kill what the god
in this world okay okay but wait give it
like give it like a year I think I think
it'll be out oh my God why is norami so
high it's only a few behind well cuz nor
norami youve I think you that hurts me
so much that what has Boku Dake got
that's erased erased why why is eras
just call it [__] eras why do you do
this oh my God that's okay um all right
never seen Joy this okay let's let's
scroll up let's go back to where we
let's go back to where we let's go down
uh let's not spend too much time on
these These are Classics narat yeah
whatever Demon Slayer Demon Slayer sure
Tokyo Tokyo Ghoul and number n Hunter
Hunter this like [__] the manga
readers are carrying this way the how
much serious question that how much do
you think the opening song has
contributed to the success of Tokyo
Ghoul like 70% I think it's the only
show where the opening has done so much
[__] heavy lifting for a show
Absolutely it is the the the the intro
is M more than anything else but they
also have the the classic manga P yeah
of course yeah but
like are carrying this shot the the yeah
the the intro has done so much [__]
heavy lifting for this I'm sure there
are many people who listen to the
opening are like oh what's this from oh
I'll check that out that sounds cool
yeah I think Turk is a concept again
insane concept fumbled the bag massively
uh yeah anime did anime did I remember
the manga but yeah the [__] anime
[__] fumbled it so hard root a what
the [__] was that [__] also also we
should be banned from ever naming a show
root something we should I I the
semicolons were pushing it for me rout a
what the [__] yeah yeah that is a bit
weird whatever happened to two was two
not good enough for some people I agree
wasn't is enough yeah take that Gintama
fans I I don't know how the [__] you
guys name you'll see [__] dumbass hey
I never to gintama's like gint gint
cursive gint apostrophe gint Circle yeah
I think I've never been as annoyed as
when I saw okay to be fair as a gint fan
that [__] is annoying as [__] yeah give
give me a tack and titon season 3 part
one episode I'll agree on that I I
genuinely prefer at least I have some
indication of what the [__] this is what
the [__] is a rout no my my least
favorite is when there's like it's
slightly different like working season
one has one exclamation mark and then
season two has two exclamation marks
it's like [__] I think we should bring
back Roman numerals for
everything just keep it easy all
right we about uh your name yes yes yes
I [__] love your name yeah yeah get
the [__] out guys get the [__] out your
name I I godamn love your name wait my
her Academia is number six right second
season that's crazy yeah my Academia
season 1 is six and season 2 is what was
it 16 but that that show that show not
only dominated Japan it absolutely
dominated online and like the entire
world for 2016 yeah absolutely it just
ran it I think it ran online I'm
surprised that can we go up to the
rating I'm surprised it's rated that
lowy the F the low 7.88 7.88 um because
I you know this is before everyone kind
of like fell out of love with my
Academia
and considering that Demon Slayer is
8.49 as well for the season 1 that is
crazy to think it's more popular than
Demon Slayer well on my anime list
definitely not like this is uh this is I
mean the rating also speaks a little bit
there yeah my anime list is I think a
good indicator of the western anime
Community it also doesn't factor in
current popularity very well exactly
exactly yeah because if you ask Japanese
people kimito is 10 out of 10 actually
you know what I am shocked one piece
isn't in the top
10 I'm not surprised by that just I it's
crazy to me to think that more people
have watched Tokyo Ghoul Hunter Hunter
Naruto I'm not surprised by that just
purely because of the sheer length of
one piece but H Hunter is long too I'm
surprised people have watched more of
Hunter Hunter than than yeah I I'm not
surprised either cuz a lot of people get
confused when I say hey one piece wasn't
that like out of the big three it wasn't
that popular and I remember like modern
anime
caught me up being like what the [__]
you talking about one piece is like
right now it is one of the most popular
I saw that CU someone called you out for
it and then all the comments were like
no no he's right
yeah let my boy cook like there was a
time when people were clowning on one
piece fans that's why I never got into
it and it was not because one piece fans
were insufferable at the times it
because no one was watching one piece at
the time yeah the reason why I never
even got into one p knew that it always
existed no one spoke about it when I was
getting into anime which was like 2013
uh to like 200 it was it was a quiet
favorite for a lot of people during
because the four kids dub just ruined so
much of One Piece image do you remember
that yeah oh yeah my favorite anime
opening let's scroll down yeah
Stein that that's it's got to be Legacy
I I imagine this was a lot higher five
years ago and it slowly keeps going as
more shows keep popping up Nar sh K No
Game No Life at 17 genuinely I I think
JJ kaon is gonna get top it's going to
get the top five I think I I can't see
it with with what's just happened with
the current season I can't see this not
going in the top five it's going to get
higher for sure it's it's I think wait
oh there's one piece is there is there a
way back machine of this page I'd love
to see one from like a year ago and see
where jiujitsu kaisen like how much it's
grown in one year if you just go by to
way back
machine uh and type in and just type in
the copy paste the link uh if you go
yeah just copy paste the link from that
page and put it in and then there should
be a ton of screenshots from dates yeah
I'd love to see how much it's even gone
up in like 3 months um so you can go to
like just go to 2022 yeah go to the end
of 2022 so just I still think it was
always pretty like it was pretty Popular
by yeah22 and then click the highlighted
yeah that one I wonder how big this
image is though sometimes it takes a
while to load yeah I mean I still think
it was always pretty damn popular Jon
actually got popular yeah pretty fast
compared to some other shun wow this
list hasn't changed much yeah it hasn't
changed much go to
16 oh it's not there it's not there G oh
it's 20 okay so it hasn't changed that
much but wait how much that means it's
gone up it's G five places oh sorry four
places four places Sor I think it's
going to keep going up though I think
yeah yeah it's going to keep going up uh
I feel like this time next year it's
going to be very close to the top 10 if
not in the top 10 latest season of J
kaon uh season 2 has completely blown
its popularity out of the window and
it's in
fortnite that's the most important
that's how we gauge the popularity of a
show nowaday uh No Game No Life No Game
No Life in 17 is [__] insane to me
why it's why yeah what you mean why why
is it so up there yeah bro it's another
show for gamers yeah what do you also
also gamers are the most
underrepresented group of all time also
this also I think this show just
visually was so appealing to so many
people because it is still to this day
one of the most like unique in terms of
like visuals from popular shows where
it's like who this is in this looks
insane I remember watching this when it
was airing and it was like the only show
that anyone cared about at the time
there wasn't much though there was there
really wasn't no it was a really slow
year uh I mean it's are you sure you
want to say that a [__] year for anime
2014 it it doesn't deserve to be that
high up there 17th most popular anime of
all time uh that's wild above season
three I say and I say this as the eai
guy um it was a fun show yeah that that
was it you know genuinely a mystery how
it never got a season to uh given it
popular still ask for it today it's
crazy it was so popular they like what
if we give you uh a prequel in a movie
form that you never asked for and people
like thanks yeah Japan has but I will
admit recently Japan's gotten a lot
better when a show is popular they will
just make a season two but I feel like
back then they were like n we're good
what what what confuses me is that anime
is going through a phase right now where
they're just digging out any show that
had any modum of popularity oh CU
they're trying to make more anime yeah
yeah and now and they're not digging up
No Game No Life what the [__] Dev
there's a parttime has a second season
like how dude spicon wolf has a new
season SP wolf has a remake what's going
with No Game No Life yeah it is weird
yeah and then we also got one piece 19
that's only going to keep going it has
going uh silent
voice I hate my anime list I hate that
you do this why just put silent voice
we're in English why I don't understand
in Japan it's called
qu